they voted voted unanimously to approve
the mandate this week and it takes
effect in just a few months madison
kimbrough heard from students and
parents tonight she joins us live from
nevada state college with their reaction
madison
i spoke to one father who is adamant
that it should be his son's choice on
whether or not to get vaccinated and you
can see we're here at nevada state
college and several other colleges and
universities across the state will now
implement this vaccination plan to stop
the spread of the virus to all the
higher ed students out there if you have
not yet done so i want to encourage
those who plan to return to in-person
learning to get your covit 19
vaccination before returning to campus
after a four-hour meeting where
officials heard from nevada students
themselves the board of health made the
decision in a unanimous vote to mandate
kofi 19 vaccines of enshi's campuses
that includes but not limited to unlv
nevada state college unr and college of
southern nevada before the vote was made
students from all over the state voice
their opinion on the matter some in
favor of the mandate while others
feeling like it's a violation of their
human rights i urge you to require copa
19 vaccines for college students many
people are worried about any possible
long-term side effects of the coba 19
vaccine however we know exactly what
happens when people contract the virus
people die hundreds of thousands of
americans are dead i do not agree with
you trying to force me to get this
vaccine and it is not fair that my
education could be at forfeit that i do
not get to finish my degree next
semester because i do not wish to put
this in my body tony marquez's son goes
to nevada state college in henderson and
says he's upset about the decision the
board of health has made stating that he
feels the system is holding people's
livelihoods hostage in money and energy
the sacrifice people have gone to go to
school
and
they want to say no you can't come back
unless you take the shot
i don't think it's right
state health officials say students need
to show proof of vaccination by november
first in order to enroll in the spring
2022 semester reporting live madison
kimbrough 8 news now